Yeah.
Here we go.
In five,
four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
Ladies and gentleman,
Joe Schilling and Daniel Straus.
Fucking house Joe Shillings.
Just fucking up my kick machine out there,
man.
That thing it read and write.
I mean,
I hope not.
I really hurt my ego.
You are light in that fucker on fire.
That thing is not right.
We've got to get that recalibrated chosen.
Chosen here,
complaining about a sciatic pain in his hip and still out kicked me.
I'm like,
what is going on out here?
Most sweaty.
Forget about cyanic pain.
Daniel Straus.
You've gone through some fucking pain,
dude.
You are defying science and doctors and that David talent,
you,
it was over.
Tell everybody the whole story.
Put this,
bring this sucker up here,
right
how the story goes.
I was out one night,
buddy.
Your mom's having trouble and needed somebody to go out with them.
So,
uh,
it was around the city that night.
And um,
after taking him home we were leaving the highway.
How's it split off?
I was coming around was like,
yeah,
I was on a bike and I had a passenger.
So what was called eight 26 is the highway as a splits off to 95.
I was going around eight,
26.
Now here's the tricky part.
Don't really remember what's going on from there.
So the what me and the passenger of,
remember we were hit from either the side or from the back.
Um,
but coming around the bin,
boom,
coming around,
it got pushed into the wall.
I wake up under the,
uh,
go out real,
can't move,
you know,
uh,
nobody else is there and the car is gone.
There was not really a witness there until like later pulling up behind us.
So it fucked me up for a while.
I mean,
fuck me up right now,
but,
you know,
uh,
getting back to just what it is,
the body's healing.
And then,
so what was the extent of your injuries?
All right.
So,
uh,
I had,
um,
in my c four,
five and six,
uh,
I had contusions on my spinal cord and half of my,
on the left side of my spinal cord,
it was,
uh,
pressure so bad that it like shut down my whole nervous system.
Like all my body.
So,
uh,
am I up in my neck and then my middle of my back was just compressed a lot of
the swelling and that's what,
uh,
caused a lot of the,
you know,
not being able to walk,
not being able to feel that nervous problems.
Never system that I have are the nervous,
uh,
issues that I had.
So what did they do to fix it?
I've been rehabbing a,
they wanted to do surgery right away,
but how many months ago was this?
This was in December [inaudible] 17.
So,
um,
they wanted to do re,
uh,
they wanted her to do a surgery immediately.
You know what I'm trying to tell him,
like,
no,
I'm,
I'm trying to fight again,
blah,
blah.
What kind of surgery?
Fuse,
that's what they wanted to do.
They wanted to go in and take the,
I think the,
I want to say the three to five or four to six or something fuse out altogether,
which obviously there's no rain that's,
and it's a big spot.
So,
uh,
wasn't trying to have that looked up for,
we looked for a couple of rehab places and eventually got hooked up with a place
called a Neil fit three 60.
So I've been rehabbing there since the accident and I mean it's,
it's in Pembroke pines,
Florida,
close to Miami,
a great crew.
Um,
but yeah,
they've been giving me back in the game.
I've been a,
I was doing that extensively every day for like two days a week,
two hour or couple of hours a day,
you know,
two to three times a day kind of shit that they do for your neck.
Uh,
for more for me,
first we had to start with um,
you know,
just uh,
the fine motor stuff,
touching,
feeling,
you know,
I had problems where it's my sensitivities.
So like you wake up under the guard rail,
you know,
you guys don't remember what happened when you wake up in the hospital.
What did they tell you?
Four,
they got all this stuff.
They were like,
oh to walk cause you feel,
could you like how were you when you woke up?
Because for me,
um,
when I woke up,
boom.
Yeah.
So back to the store when I woke up,
when I woke up,
help.
So I woke up and uh,
you know,
I had my helmet on but I couldn't move my legs.
Um,
my passenger had one over top.
She had,
uh,
her,
her hands,
so she wasn't like extremely,
but she had went out too.
So I couldn't really feel nothing cause see nothing.
I was just telling him to get my helmet off and get my helmet off.
Finally a truck had pulled up and a seeing that we were in an accident and they,
what they shouldn't,
shouldn't do but pull me out and uh,
yeah cause I was,
you know,
get me out of here,
I was freaking out.
They pulled me out from under it and uh,
you know,
going to the hospital,
that whole,
the scary part was,
was knowing nothing was broke but not being able to feel nothing.
Trying to wipe my face or trying to grab something and he just couldn't move
your mind in my head and my head,
I'll move my leg or move my arm.
Nothing's going on.
You know what I'm saying?
So you're thinking you're paralyzed.
I'm going.
That's a wrap.
Like Paul Williams,
just like fuck.
So I get to the,
uh,
hospital finally.
Um,
you know,
they're trying to work on me and uh,
seeing the doctors,
he's telling me,
well,
you know,
because of my neck,
it's unlikely that I'll be,
you know,
walking anytime soon.
No,
a couple of days,
couple of weeks ago after that,
you know,
just banging out.
And in the meantime I'm trying to explain to them I'm an athlete.
I know you see this,
I've been through this type of incident before.
You know,
I grew up wrestling,
I'm from Cincinnati,
grew up wrestling,
so I've had neck problems for fuck my whole life,
you know what I mean?
And,
uh,
so I'm trying to explain to him like,
you know,
chill out.
Just give me some time.
Let me,
let me work something out.
I don't want to do the surgery right now.
I really want to,
they want you to do it in the hospital right there.
Right.
Then there,
there is no other,
you know,
there's no other choice.
You never going to walk a game.
You got to go back to them right now and go,
hey motherfucker,
look,
it was walking around.
You know what I mean?
And it's been like that majority of times in my career where I've done
something,
something's happened.
Oh,
you're not going to be able to do this.
You got me fucked up.
He's hitting pads with me at the gym yesterday,
sparring.
This happened in fucking December.
That's insane.
It's just insane.
It just makes me sick that they always want to cut you immediately when it comes
to those things,
kind of bulging disc issue,
they want to get in there and it,
it's hurtful to us because,
you know,
I understand they got a job to do,
but do your job.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like they have the one method is Thursday.
So,
um,
but yeah,
like I said,
I was rehabbing a neuro fit three,
six d,
which is just the great death physical therapy place down there and Pembro prize
and uh,
you know,
I've been getting back with,
uh,
you know,
they had me strengthened my neck with just small exercises.
Like I said,
I started with fine motor stuff while I had to work on a lot of balance stuff,
you know.
Um,
you ever fuck with that iron neck thing?
You ever used that thing yet?
No.
Have not used one out here.
I'm try if you want to mess around with it and he's fantastic.
Fantastic.
Low too.
So you are six months out now.
Six months out.
Start walking again.
It took me,
uh,
like even now I'm still like trying to get the form right.
But uh,
it took me about three months because she was like,
read,
learning how to tie your shoe.
We learned how to tie your shoe in my hand.
My Motor,
like my hand wasn't moving his right,
it wasn't working as good.
Um,
it's just,
everything's slowed down for me because of him,
because of my spinal cord.
So wow.
You know,
that is the most for me was the scariest part because I was everything so
unsure,
you know what I mean?
The most recent MRI,
when did you get,
have you gotten more,
uh,
gobble in about a month and a half ago?
Ever since look good.
It looks good.
Every,
all the swollen.
His went down.
The left side is clear.
Uh,
the only way I can explain it,
there's two,
two months,
white lines and it gets blocked.
You know what I'm saying?
That's where the fluids coming down.
My left side of my,
on the fluid was being blocked.
So now I'm having a clear line of fluid going down my spinal cord.
Now it's just about healing,
which,
you know,
I've been working that and that's the part to get overcome.
You know,
the healing part,
the,
the neurological part and the nerves and all that part that goes with it.
It's the body that can only,
there's not too much that I can do to,
to tell this other than,
you know,
eating right.
All of the simple shit.
But it's the body.
That's Helen.
That's crazy that you're sparring.
Yeah,
I do a lot of things I shouldn't do now.
He's partying with friends so you know that everything's going to be cool.
I mean,
good training partners.
So I was born down at Henry who's h kickboxing was training down there.
Um,
so,
you know,
I live in Fort Lauderdale,
so,
you know,
that's,
working out with those guys,
you know,
no one's out there to hurt me or tried to get me hurt or injured.
Everyone's had a lot of respect and love seeing me back.
So I've never been in a situation where I'm trying to go super hard.
Not yet,
but I love to.
Right.
Well,
you can get it.
Let me know.
We can get it.
So when you hit in the bag or hitting pads,
you feel like you have full strength.
Um,
no,
no.
And that's the thing that I'm excited about.
I'm a broken toward that is dying to be fixed.
You know what I mean?
Cause I'm a brand new,
you know,
I can be fixed in any way.
Like I'm relearning everything.
I'm not,
you know,
it's not like I can't box,
it's not like I can't wrestle,
but it's now just relearning the,
you know,
the mechanics of making your brain knows how to do it,
but your body's got to relearn it.
Exactly why.
And it's like the nerve,
the nerve stuffs is on the right side of your body.
Right,
right.
It's like muscle memory coming back.
Even yesterday I was holding pads from like,
his job was a little weak and like his,
his uh,
lifting of his foot or whatever the thing we were trying to do.
But once as we were doing it,
once he felt the right way to do it,
then he can repeat it.
You know what I mean?
I think that's a lot.
So it was lots of did it and this big for me,
man,
I really want to be back in,
in the cage by the end of this year.
Really.
You know what I mean?
I want to be fighting about an issue and it's not impossible.
Well,
you got a great attitude,
man.
This idea that you love it,
that you're a broken toy and you're going to rebuild it and fix it.
And it's exciting because it gives you an opportunity to kind of start again.
I mean,
that's been my whole life my whole life.
So I'm just there again at this point in my career.
And unfortunately this had to happen for me to turn the corner and get focused
in another way.
But you know,
it's just what it has to be.
But it's so exciting that you have this attitude that's the,
that's the cool thing about it.
It's like you're not,
woe is me.
You're like,
Hey,
I'm on a rebuild,
but I'm gonna get right back in there.
Hey Man.
I mean,
you must be so excited that you could just do everything again.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like first was fun and now what work had been making sure to Dick work
first,
it was like,
all right,
always fuck off my back,
making sure I can do shit.
Yeah.
You know,
the first,
you know,
first couple of months it was just brutal,
not being a weapon of mass coming to eat
in this.
Did it slowly start to come back where you got like some motion dude.
Well and I've had um,
a lot of,
uh,
I think it's just the notice files,
the gnosis wrestling for 40 years,
you know what I mean?
Source.
Um,
do you do any decompression?
I do a little bit here and there and whenever I can get to the chiropractors I'm
doing some or you know,
like I said,
it's been bad for you.
Have you seen that thing you hook up to your neck and yet hang from a doorway,
stretch it.
Do I do that same thing with a rolled up towel or bang it from the doorway and
it helps mind tremendously.
But I got mine,
I'm sure from fighting.
But then also like I'll lay on my back at night,
I'll watch
for like two weeks.
My neck will be all,
you know,
isn't it crazy?
You're a professional fight or you fuck up your back watching youtube videos?
For sure.
But everyone was doing it.
Man.
That's all we do is take the whole world is doing it is people's necks are
changing.
Yeah.
It's terrible if it wasn't for like,
you know,
being new awareness that I have now for like my neck and neck injuries,
just seeing a lot of things.
I'm like trying to posture up and just see you and shit cause I'm just,
I'm always like this,
always heard,
always hurting him.
So,
you know,
it's been one thing after another four years and that's actually leading into
this,
you know,
this accident with a or this injury,
um,
try to keep this mic closer
to you.
So are you,
how old are you now Daniel?
I am 33.
I'll be 34.
I'm at that age where you forget how old you are.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I'll be 34 in July.
Well you're,
you're healthy and you know,
the ability to recuperate from something that's that devastating,
that quickly shows what could of shape you're in.
That must have a big impact on your rehab process.
Right?
Does it does,
I mean,
a regular person that has that kind of injury probably is not going to bounce
back like that.
Not as quickly.
I mean,
being,
like I said,
being an athlete has helped me tremendously.
I mean with my neck,
Korean obviously as strong as it was,
the,
you know,
the damage would have been worse.
But,
uh,
being able to bounce backwards been,
you know,
being young,
being able to,
I put my body through so much that this is,
yeah.
Compared to what,
you know,
it's been through.
So yeah,
being young it's definitely helped me and I'm trying to keep that,
that,
that time away,
but you know,
so how will you know when you can get back in there?
Are you wrestling yet?
Yeah.
Wrestling and doing everything.
He restaurant Breslin Russell.
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
nervous about getting your neck Yank Dawn.
And I was nervous before,
you know what I mean?
But now I'm just getting confident with getting my neck strong,
making sure I don't do the stupid moves I've been doing the caused the injury.
So,
um,
my next step is just being clear,
being seen by a doctor,
a neurologist.
Yes.
He can fight,
sign off,
let's get back to business.
So,
and how's bell toward treating all of this great man.
I can't say anything negative about them because they've always done nothing but
help me out in situations.
Uh,
you know,
I've been with them for some time,
and uh,
two times world champion if y'all motherfuckers didn't know.
But uh,
yeah,
they've
always,
they've always,
they've always been fair to me.
That's great.
Obviously you've always had problems here and there,
but I've never really had any major,
you know,
Scott Coker?
I do too.
So I always been good to me.
I hear nothing but good things too about how they treat people.
Like guys who have gone over there said it's a,
it's just a huge relief to get treated with respect.
You know,
like they were a little nervous about going over there.
All right,
right.
You know,
a lot of people would always asking,
Hey,
what do you want it?
I'm like,
Eh,
this is home for me.
You know what I mean?
Like the all ideal for everybody would be bell toward gets to the same state as
the UFC,
the same level.
That would be ideal.
That would help the world.
Like if you see Gennady Golovkin fighting Canelo Alvarez,
you don't give a fuck if it's golden boy versus Bob Arum course that they want
to see too far.
Champions go after it.
That's,
that's what everybody wants to see.
Ultimately.
That's what I would like to see across the board.
You know,
I mean I don't think it harms anybody.
I think it helps everybody.
Definitely good.
Better for everybody.
It's better for the athletes for sure.
You know,
and the more money that's gets thrown around and the more,
I mean if,
if a superstar merges from Bella tour that's at the same level that Rhonda was
or Connor is or something like that,
that's great for everybody.
For everybody.
And you know,
there's a possibility there too.
I mean Michael Van and pages,
he's getting a lot of mainstream press.
People were paying attention to him now cause the other crazy shit he doesn't.
That's all right.
We need more of that.
I thought he actually had retired from him and may cause boxed for awhile,
like retired from them may box to something.
Nothing.
You know what man,
dude like that.
Probably when we retire and unretired just for the press,
you know,
it just seems to be the thing have is a lot
speaking and retiring and retiring.
Joe Shelan back to MMA.
I know you competed in the high rollers event this weekend,
which by the way,
Eddie Bravo told me he was so high,
he thought it was going to jail.
He told me,
he goes,
I was convinced I was going to jail because I was so paranoid.
It was such a cool event.
It really was the event for people don't know what the fuck we're talking about
as an event.
Put on my mat style and a big lawn on my buddies.
The Coldwell high rollers and it's a cannabis infused,
a Jujitsu tournament is with nick all day.
You know,
what are those two dudes that slapped each other and then they,
they smoked a joint together.
He knew there something in between and then they stepped out with a joint.
I mean,
it was good though.
Before every match,
everybody smoked like kind of smoked together.
The whole event is kind of this thing.
There was no alcohol.
The vibe was super chill.
They played um,
like a hip hop in the background.
It was wow.
It was like kind of press star studded event.
It was really fucking cool.
Is it?
That is by far the coolest martial arts event I've ever been to.
It was dope.
Shout out to the DJ man.
He did like eight hours straight playing the same song.
Like only twice paid it twice,
right?
I'm off always dope.
Oh really?
Oh thing get Bollix it was it.
It's a weird connection.
Marijuana with Jujitsu and it's always been there and people that don't know if
people that don't smoke weed,
I have to tell them that.
Look that his Jeff Glover
and his opponent smoking weed.
It's hilarious man.
It is really,
really fun and that they're doing that man.
But I like it.
Oh,
why is your real cool event?
It was real cool Jujitsu and we'd have always been connected.
As long as I've been doing Jujitsu.
People smoked pot in the parking lot and then went in and rolled.
Right.
That's still do kickboxing apparently is the same way because it's how you
practice focus.
I always found that I'm not good at learning when I'm high or maybe I get too
high and I can't learn like,
like some old show me something and I'm not sure where to put my legs.
Like what do I do?
Step over here,
what I put my right foot,
what?
Yeah.
I find that,
but when I'm rolling,
if I'm rolling high then it just,
you just get into that zone
rubbing like a few,
you know,
like when they say like,
uh,
if you take a,
if when you study for a test,
you're sucking on peppermint and then the day of the test you take pepper,
you like suck on peppermint.
You supposed to help you remember?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I feel like that's kind of how it is
with,
uh,
with martial arts.
For me anyway,
like I'm high as fuck and I'm kind of like just a programming into my deep
subconscious or whatever.
Yeah,
I know.
That's my thought.
Maybe you think smoking all the time when you try and then smoking,
not smoking.
When you performed,
do you think that has a like a positive or negative effect?
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't really,
well,
well let me ask you this.
The first time I felt towards said we're not testing for weed.
You could fight high as fuck.
What would you do that smoked that day?
Whoo.
I wouldn't smoke probably 10 minutes before I got out of shit going on in my
head.
This is cool.
The high rollers with that.
But like,
yeah,
it's different.
Lot of money on the line through it fight.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
you know,
the consequences are a lot different,
zigging and zagging Rhett's a lot different when you kicks and punches are being
thrown.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Well remember when Nate d or nick rather a fuck go me nick.
Fuck me home.
Well,
I mean,
I know nick and I,
if you asked him that question,
he's like,
oh,
have you spoken to right there?
And like he would for sure.
For sure.
100% I bet he would fight better.
Probably.
Yeah.
Not a fan of it.
You're not a fan of fighting.
Hi.
No,
no,
no fault.
One time.
What happened?
Well,
for once,
for once I went through the crowd instead of the,
the walkway.
Well,
how did you do,
do it
like you,
you're supposed to come out.
It was at shark fights.
Okay.
And uh,
you'd come out and then you go at an l shape and go straight to the cage.
Right.
I came out,
the ushers always fuck that shit up though.
That's happened like every time he tried to walk out the cage the wrong way.
Anyway,
so I came out just the crowd sitting there and just beeline straight to the
crowd.
Excuse me.
Stepping over.
People got to the cage,
like stepped over the fence.
Check me out.
Got it down.
I'm like,
God,
I remember shark fights.
That was a bud.
Brotzmann his thing.
He's a buddy of mine.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
He was one of the original guys that own king of the cage.
Was it?
Yeah,
I did.
And they didn't get involved in shark fights.
Yeah.
Somebody,
did they have something to do with like Sean fights as well?
I don't know.
So maybe this a few people involved.
It was a good car that I was on,
had a Georgie Parkdale.
They had uh,
uh,
[inaudible] uh,
fuck.
What's the bunch of people and um,
hmm.
So what was it like fighting high?
Well,
for me at the time,
that was my biggest event and I'm was fighting,
uh,
Karen Double Radians.
So it was the biggest name I had fought
to me.
It was like,
fuck.
You know what I mean?
I just was kinda overwhelmed.
I wasn't a Jujitsu.
I didn't know much about you just to actually,
the whole fight was weird because on Monday I separated,
my arm are separated my shoulder.
Wednesday they called me for the fight.
Saturday I fought.
Okay.
Separate years,
like,
I guess I'll get high for this.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Why you separate?
Separated show like what,
like separation,
like a separated shoulder,
like a torn myself.
No,
no,
no.
Um,
yeah,
up in the,
um,
I don't know what the fuck you asked me.
He love them.
Yeah,
well we got it like bandaged up,
got to work in,
fought with it.
He didn't fight,
would've been bandaged up,
but the next two days kinda held on it.
Ice.
It worked on as much as I can.
Went out there.
Uh,
it was in Texas fought and uh,
yeah,
I was just,
for me it was weird.
Like I said,
go one decision.
Uh,
like I said at first round he got through a bunch of like Lego blocks.
Yeah.
He's a serious spools his leg.
That's what I was saying.
Like,
hi [inaudible] don't know what's going on.
I
just want to get out of here.
So it was,
it was a bad thing for me.
So one and done first fight and high done.
I was like,
yeah.
Cool.
Have you ever fought?
Hi?
Uh,
I mean I'm sure I fought at spar high all the time.
uh,
hi.
What's your feeling about that?
I think it like a,
for this Jujitsu tournament,
you know,
Jujitsu is not my strong suit obviously.
And so for me,
that was my first Jiu Jitsu tournament and uh,
we just put it on the g like about a month ago when Matt told me about that
things like,
oh,
I should do it.
And Micky Gall I train with every day and uh,
him and Bomba and we like,
all right,
fuck it,
we'll do it.
So we start putting on the g and a,
yeah,
it was,
um,
I didn't want to make a fool of myself.
So being high and having that like pressure,
like not being completely comfortable.
I think it was different.
But like in a kickboxing fight I could probably be drunk and still be pretty
comfortable with.
Yeah.
This is a lot of people that think that,
and I'm one of them that think that marijuana is a performance enhancing drug.
I don't think so.
On a certain,
on certain levels,
certain levels.
I think you could fuck you up,
but,
but it's,
if you get the dose right,
I think you puts you in a zone in our comfortable zone.
Right.
And I think that the,
a lot of mean for performance,
like how well it's going to increase your performance is not being super
stressed out over bullshit the weekend.
That's where I find the most benefit.
Like when I would quit smoking weed for a couple of days before the fight,
that was when it's like now's when I needed it the most and I was one the most
stressed out is when I have the most anxiety.
When I have the hungriest they can,
you know,
I was like,
this sucks.
I can just play it and just relax.
I think that helps.
Hey Man,
are you doing any cryotherapy or anything to reduce swelling?
A little,
like I said,
I was doing a little bit with uh,
the,
um,
I'm trying to like the chiropractor that I was going to,
but I haven't done much of it.
But that's one thing I would really want you to get into because of the swelling
a lot.
Like I said,
a lot of it's went down over the,
over the time,
but body feels amazing after her crowd.
Yeah.
Dude,
I'm a big fan.
I like super doses of CBD though too.
Yeah,
a lot of CBD.
A lot of that in that bag he gave me.
Yeah,
check that out.
That's a some flavor rec stuff that a flavor
stop.
Crazy shirt in there too.
There is quite a few.
You can't stop crying this morning.
I'm like,
is he a medium or large or an extra large and I was just Brooklyn.
Fuck fuck.
I put large,
isn't there?
Perfect.
So strength for you Joe.
What is a company called?
Flave?
A CBD company.
I've been working with the pen.
Yeah,
like medicated drops.
I get it gives you like a certain dose every time you click it.
Oh,
I've been using,
um,
you ever heard of that company Jambo?
They just sent me some CBD.
A Rub on Holy Shit.
Does that work for you?
Fuck yeah.
2000 milligrams.
CBD Rub on.
I told you this sciatic pains been fucking with me or the last week or so and a,
I rub it on my hip like it's like my ass muscle and right over like right here.
That's where it like it,
it travels down and I rubbed that shit on before I go to bed.
Cause Flavor has these uh,
they have like medicated patches you can use to have roll ons that you could use
it if it's solve stuff.
I just feel like I smoked so much weed with CBD and it all the time that it
don't,
it doesn't seem to work for me.
I don't notice it.
You know.
And then they have these droppers.
I use that like crazy.
Yeah.
Maybe you just got too much of a tolerance.
Well I just think if you,
you know,
if you smoke weed constantly there's CBD and everything,
you're hitting both.
So like when when my coach who's was like 65 and never smoked weed and I give
him put it that shit on him,
he's like,
oh my God,
my elbow feels correct me.
I'm just like,
Eh,
I'll get you some of that jumbo shit.
It's better than anything I've ever used before.
They have two versions.
They have a 300 milligram in 2000 milligram and I put that 2000 milligram arm
and it's got like a menthol in it.
So you feel it like when your skin like Ooh,
heats up.
Tell him I really have a feeling that is like using it on my neck.
Yeah.
Like using on my neck and I've used it on my hand to where I've liked the
achiness does the achiness goes
away.
But on my neck as well,
I felt it the most like up in the pain.
But I put out this CBD vaporizers and then there's CBD bath bomb and he used
that before my buddy's fight.
The day of the fight,
we dropped it in the uh,
and the hot tub
CBD Balms some fucking monsters out there that trying to make this illegal.
It is crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Pharmaceutical.
Those guys.
Fuck those guys.
So scary that someone would do that.
They would try to spend money to try to make this stuff illegal.
And then while they're doing that,
they legalize like the fucking GMO synthetic version,
which is like actually killing Zack.
Seriously.
Fuck.
Those people were fentanyl.
That shit's killing.
Everybody killed Prince.
It killed David.
Bowie had killed.
Who the fuck else are?
They killed it.
Killed it.
Killed a bunch of people this year.
Tom Petty Killed Tom Petty too.
Did he kill David?
Go or make that up so I'm killed.
David Bowie.
Who knows what's the ball?
What's that?
That's a,
that's a CBD bath bomb.
Dang.
You just drop that in.
That's it.
That's fucking not fucking around.
That's his legit,
they still good time.
I really feel like a rub on effect from CBD is like I'll soak in one of those.
Just never did the bathroom.
Yeah,
it's good.
Yeah.
And it's fun to watch you dropped it in and I'll just August.
I got a lot of shit in here.
Write some stuff Joe.
Beautiful.
I got some good little,
uh,
you know,
to Chili's and edible.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Citing Max got it off.
This is awesome.
I take this on my international flights.
Allegedly.
The key folks of law is illegal.
It's illegal,
but it's a,
when you put the the vape pen and do it [inaudible] it looks like a car key
security.
Oh that's crazy.
I miss lot the bathroom.
So you screw that.
Decide the caps on from given that he put it in there.
And these look at these candy.
So jazz.
So my complaint about the candy thing is if they're going to have like a,
um,
that those are CBD,
but they have a THC wants to and if you're going to have THC,
like super potent candy,
they shouldn't taste so fucking good because I'll eat the whole bag.
You know what I mean?
Like who's going to eat just one?
That's very good.
That's watermelon.
Watermelon bags at once.
Yeah.
This is watermelon belts.
It's like a belt.
Super lucky dude.
Check your shit.
This is the shit.
Look at this thing.
I love it.
And then I think it has like a,
there's three different settings.
Repeat or how you burn it.
These kids today,
oh,
you got to turn it off five times.
Click it fund on to the other side.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Nope.
Can you maybe that's the heat up,
getting more into Joe fucking it up their job that you got it.
You got it.
You got to go on.
Maybe it had to heat up.
There it goes.
Burn it.
How was a ballad tours,
drug testing policy standard.
We don't have like the additional,
uh,
you saw the random tests,
but I get tested before or after every fight.
I haven't tested.
Most of them are boys.
I know that.
Yeah.
So,
and I've had people talk shit like,
oh,
they won't tell us like,
well,
I'll know what he's talking about the test after fights.
But obviously there's a big difference between that and hey,
it's four weeks out,
wake up at six 30 in the morning.
What do you been up to,
Daniel here pissing his cup.
Look at that.
It's Taro.
It's crazy.
I mean they,
they have lost a lot of people off the roster in the UFC.
The really crazy thing is the body's changing.
Yeah.
Like people you weren't sure,
you know,
everybody passed the test when they were doing it on the way in day,
but then you're looking at their bodies changed like,
Whoa,
this guy.
So many of them just shriveled up and they just look totally different in their
performances are different.
Their mindset's different guys that were just unstoppable and they saw that came
in sixth fight,
losing streak,
crazy drop two weight classes get away.
Anybody who says it's steroids doesn't work.
It's crazy.
Fucking mine.
They're not taking it for fun.
Right.
You know,
they're not going all the way down to Tijuana and get by in this shit because
it's,
it's fun to good to do on the weekend.
So do you feel like you got a new lease on life?
Um,
I do a man right now I'm just grinding,
like fully focused on getting back into the cage.
Like,
you know,
having,
having what happened to me and being in a position that I'm in,
I don't really have too many things to go back to them.
So,
you know,
having a new lease on life really isn't how I would say it is.
It's just what it is.
I'm just focused on the next step,
you know what I mean?
The next step in my career,
the next step and you know,
the path and what I've been going through,
you know,
it's always just something for me.
So,
you know,
I wouldn't say it's a new lease of life,
but just a new chapter.
But you must feel very fortunate that you,
you can recover from that.
Do I do?
Um,
it's amazing story.
I love hearing shit.
Like
I agree.
It's a,
it just sucks.
You know what I mean?
It sucks to be in this position,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm here,
I'm talking to you,
talking to this guy,
you know,
walking around.
So I'm blessed more than anything,
but this is just fired me up to just get shit going on.
You know what I mean?
So you got to feel pretty fucking unstoppable after that.
Go flying to check in before this shit and you come back like,
what's going to stop?
Yeah,
that's the goal.
Get another belt,
get back,
get another belt,
show people.
I'm not,
you know,
not done at all.
You know,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I'm even still running.
Are you really fucking savage?
Jesus Christ.
Just say one 76 the other day,
dude,
I'd be an h one.
The real one real hummer.
I'd be in one of those bitches and I'd ride in the middle of it.
Right.
I figured out a way to,
if we put the steering wheel in the middle,
but I don't want to be on either side and strapped me with a race harness and
put fucking airbags everywhere.
I want this thing to be like an inflatable bath toy,
but I'm an,
I'm an
adrenaline junkie,
so I love to do anything,
you know,
I shouldn't be riding obviously,
but uh,
you know,
I need something to study my mind.
So like I said,
training,
training has been going,
something I got back into riding,
something I got back into and it's pushing me to like move forward.
Would it be,
how long was it before you wrote again?
I probably started riding again
maybe about a month and a half.
What about a month ago?
About a month ago.
A month ago.
Okay.
Not a month then.
So five months after the injury at probably about a month.
If you did a month after Andrea,
like this dude is fucking crazy.
Get barely walk.
That's some shit.
I would try them.
I mean I would definitely try it.
But what do you think makes you such an adrenaline junkie?
I don't know.
Even right before all my fights
it's like,
it's just been that way.
Like I would always ride a lot before my fights because I had to release,
you know,
all the adrenaline,
the,
all the pent up like anxiety,
anxiety going on and that's just how I've always been,
you know?
I've always wanted to see what was it like to kill yourself,
What was it like to foot back,
you know what I mean?
Like adrenaline wise,
what was it like to do something fun and exciting?
Push the limit,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That sounds very different than I didn't mean it like that.
I mean Diego corrals,
he died in a motorcycle accident.
Right?
Paul Williams,
you know,
he got fucked up.
There's so many fighters that have gotten into motorcycles for that.
The reason,
but it's not just motorcycles.
I mean I've done until all type of shit.
Like what else?
I mean dive and I love diving.
Water is one of my favorite things.
The ocean is one of my favorite things to do.
You know,
I've never been in any situation where I'm about to die or anything,
but you know,
I want to do sky diving.
I want to do rock climb.
I don't want to do all this.
Me,
Cho Shaylin's on my page.
He and Joe are on the same page,
all that.
I don't even like roller coasters to drag me on it the first time.
Then I'm like,
we're going again.
Until that point I'm like,
no,
fuck that.
You ride bikes a little bit,
but I don't like when I go down to the ranch with Coldwell riding with them,
but they make fun of me cause I'll go like 60 once I get paid like 60 then it
starts getting my God,
I don't know,
just be cool cowboy example.
Hellboy will be fucking going down the highway 90 with his hat off,
like resize and his hat,
you know?
No hands 90 down the highway.
He's fucking not yeah.
Or snapping pictures
of us while he's riding.
Oh,
Jesus.
I don't want to hear it.
Isn't that for sure?
I love that dude.
I don't want him to get hurt.
I don't want to hear that.
Yeah,
fuck.
He's good at it,
I guess.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure he is good at fighting too,
but
it's fucking dangerous.
Just like you should dot your I's.
Cross your t's or sure.
90 on the highway.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
He's a perfect example of a legit adrenaline junkie.
Hundred percent.
A hundred percent,
hundred percent.
I guess just some people once,
I guess fighting is a big part of it.
Like once you've experienced the highs of fighting,
I guess the lows of regular life or just too fucking boring.
Is that what it is,
man?
Imagine that.
I feel like you would get,
I would definitely mammoth thought about retiring,
but when I stopped fighting,
I think that's what really bothered me
because I'm addicted to like not the adrenaline side of,
they'd be like the challenge,
like the,
you can't do this like me versus the world like that.
That really gets me going.
But I think if I didn't have that when I'm old,
I'd be pretty pissed off.
You'll versus the world.
Like how so?
Uh,
like,
or like even just me versus like me man versus man,
like one on one like that,
no other,
it's just you're the only one that you can,
you,
uh,
can count on.
And that scenario I guess.
But like that,
that personal challenge is what drives me and fuels me.
And that's what,
why like I think,
uh,
my career,
the,
the fights that I wasn't supposed to win,
we're always the ones that I really showed up for it because that Jen,
that,
that hit me where it was,
if I was supposed to,
when everyone thought I was going to win for some on some level,
I would not show up the same way.
Very common.
That's very common.
A lot of guys,
when when they think it's going to be an easy fight,
they can't get up.
They just have this weird,
and it's weird because like you don't,
you know,
your coaches won't let you not train the way.
Like you train hard for the fight,
you know,
it was just something about the thing in your head doesn't click or it doesn't,
go after it the same way.
Yeah.
It's like the thing that everybody hates the most about before a fight,
that discomfort and anxiety and just fuck,
why am I doing this?
Fuck that is what is your friend when you're in there?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's the fights.
Good.
To an extent.
That's what fucking drowns yet at the same time,
cause it'd be right people like fucking,
their whole camp is perfect and as soon as they walk out in front of that crowd,
it's like the coaches like who the fuck is this?
What the fuck's going on?
But don't you think
dabble sometimes.
But that's always that kind of person.
Like a guy.
Like you doesn't have that.
There's not,
that's not a thing that you experience.
You know?
I mean there's the type of people that crumble or usually like the guys who were
just murderers in the gym and then for whatever reason,
under the bright lights,
they falter,
but they rarely rise.
Like those guys rarely when the big fights that they're not supposed to win,
that's not the,
not the same psychological makeup.
Like something about the challenge or the unknown to some people,
it,
it just overwhelms them.
Whereas other people,
whatever their psychological makeup is,
that challenge is what fires them up.
It gets him excited.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
NC is the hard for longevity for the fighters in general and the curriculum.
That's what makes Floyd Mayweather so impressive to me is for him to be at the
top of the game for so long and can make all the money and continue to be at the
top of the game and still do that.
I mean,
versus like a,
you know,
the,
the guys that blow up and then,
you know,
Jon Jones has trouble,
they don't know how to deal with the fame,
who call on air,
throwing shit through bus windows.
Like it's hard to stay balanced and consistent through that whole,
I think from that whole thing,
uh,
my biggest one of my biggest thing has been,
you know,
the mental part of fighting,
getting to the top,
being pushed back down,
you know,
just dealing with that as a fighter has put a lot of stress on like,
every time that I got into the cage,
like how I thought or how I acted or how it performing.
Yeah.
So you,
you did some work with Vinny shoreman,
right?
Yup.
How did that help?
Uh,
Vinnie helped me a lot for,
uh,
I worked with any for I think three years,
two or three years.
And I find that,
um,
tell everybody,
Vinny chairmen's a hypnotist whose been on the show a couple times.
I was the one that had told you about the aunts,
brought him up on the phone.
Shit,
someone wants credit.
I made you Benny.
He has me.
It was a trip.
Right.
Wow.
This is real.
It really works
for me.
And then,
uh,
I find that as I've grown,
I think,
uh,
just like any technique,
you,
you get better at it and has it needs time till they kind of resonate inside of
you.
And I feel,
I mean,
I haven't worked with them in over a year and a,
I still am figuring out,
we call that was the fuck he was talking about it.
I like this is leading starts to sink in.
So I think it's been a,
the mental game is a huge,
a huge,
uh,
asset.
Do you ever work with a sports psychologist or a hypnotist or anything like
that?
I mean,
I've worked a little bit what a guy named will back in Florida.
This is some years ago,
but something I've always wanted to dabble in.
It's something I've wanted to explore.
I haven't really got the chance to do a lot of things,
but that's one thing I've always,
like I said,
the mental part is been key to me,
so I always wanted to do that.
It might be a good thing to help you during your recovery too.
You know,
like to just really concentrate on recovery and really concentrated on the parts
of your body that need to be fixed.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm,
but uh,
you know,
really need to reach out to the right people to get the right,
um,
the help as far as like,
you know,
people to talk to him as far as having tests and stuff like that.
I don't really know anybody like that.
Vinny shoreman to the rescue.
Yeah.
Well I'll let you,
yeah,
he'll,
he's probably listening.
He'll do it a over Skype too.
You do it over a,
you know,
you do a fucking facetime and he used to,
uh,
used to hypnotize me over facetime all the time and then get on fight day.
He would call me and like we'd be backstage,
he'll be back in the states in October.
Yeah.
Okay.
So
I'll look it up.
I'll make the connection.
I would definitely look into what would definitely like,
but you've been using the lion's mane mushrooms too,
right?
I saw on there,
I sent him that video and started talking to him about it when I found out about
what happened to him.
You know,
it was like,
I'm sure not as bad as what he was going through,
but like we just,
Oh,
I don't think he's going to walk again.
it's empty.
And it was in a horrible accident.
And then every time I talked to him,
he would just be like real like,
Nah,
fuck them.
It's going to happen.
It's fucked that.
And uh,
I'm like,
all right,
you need to take this lion's mane mushroom.
He needs,
some of these court is set much.
Sure.
It was take all the flavor x CBD that you can get you some other mushrooms as
good for your brain,
you'll be cool.
And uh,
I mean look at it and look what I did.
Look what I did.
Oh Joe.
Oh Joe Doing,
oh,
seeing you walking around and hearing that you're sparring and hitting the bag
and made the pads.
Yeah,
I mean all these things put together.
It's just what's given me back,
you know?
So it's nothing's impossible.
I mean,
I can prove that nothing's impossible and shit,
you know,
during them,
like you said,
even the lion's mane and the different CBDS I've been taking and the,
just getting my body back to like feeling good,
mentally feeling good,
just everything's working like in steps.
So little steps at a time.
Basically day by day,
80% now I'll give you 75 75 is good,
you know,
75 minutes you can get to a hundred you know,
like I'm running,
you know what I'm saying?
That wasn't one of my big goals was like buy in six months,
I want to be running,
set a goal,
started running,
boom.
I'm a guy who couldn't walk.
Exactly.
So that's awesome.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I don't know,
it gives me an uh,
every time I think about it,
the reason why I stopped cause cause every time I have to talk about it,
I get in the mental thought of it in the process of from going,
laying in the bed,
not be able to feel shit to,
you know,
dragging your foot after you're walking with a walker to being able to pull up
your pants now it's crazy.
It is fucking crazy.
You know what I mean?
And it just,
it keeps me,
it keeps me humble enough to just talk about the situations and love it.
Love Life.
That's a beautiful story man.
I love hearing things like that.
People recovering from things because it's just,
it makes you appreciate the fact that you are all healthy every time anything
goes wrong and your live,
it's an opportunity to appreciate what it's like when things go right.
And if you can get back to where you were,
you'll have a new perspective.
I do for sure.
For sure.
Are you fucking with that lion's mane stuff too?
Yeah.
How often you take it?
I was taking it every day.
I made a bunch of capsules,
uh,
with lion's mane and a quarter subs.
You made the capsules yourself?
Yeah,
you can,
you can buy it on Amazon little capsule machine.
They got a hundred capsules,
a little concoction there.
Nice.
Okay.
So when I saw on your,
your show a post,
the Stamets was talking about how the,
I think it was CTE,
you guys were talking about how the,
the lion's Mane helps,
uh,
find,
no,
I don't know if a repairs it or if it just helps like the,
it find a way around blockages or whatever with neural tissue or tissue.
And I was like,
oh,
Daniel,
like hit hit him up with it right
now that lion's mane stuff is miraculous.
I mean there's,
it's amazing that more people don't know about it and that more people aren't
talking about it,
but anybody that's involved in contact sports,
any athlete that,
you know,
it's getting hit and they're getting their cage rattled a lot.
They should be taking that stuff all the time.
Yeah.
And CBD as well,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
I just look at it like a,
the business that we're in is really dangerous and like,
if you know that there's something that,
you know,
uh,
guys,
we get punchy,
right?
Or guys love lose their Chin or,
uh,
have problems like performing on fight night or whatever.
Like if you can,
if you could take CBD to be better for swelling,
you can take lion's mane of repair,
the concussions and shit that we're getting constantly.
Like I just think you're kind of stupid if you're not actively trying to figure
out a solution to all these problems.
Have you ever fucked with Kratom?
I never,
I not really.
I know people that have,
I was,
um,
I was hanging out with Simon rex yesterday and he was telling me like some
awesome stories about people that were addicted to opiates.
They got off of it with Kratom.
I think it's all time erect,
Aka dirt nasty.
So good.
That's so funny,
dude.
That's an awesome dude.
I,
uh,
I took eight,
eight pills yesterday,
which,
uh,
most of the time I was taking two and then I took four and then yesterday I took
eight.
Nah.
Oh,
I get it.
That stuff makes you high as fuck.
When you take eight.
My whole body felt weird.
I was,
I was like pretending to be sober.
I was walking around and pretend to be sober,
but not like a drunk,
not,
not like reaction time.
Like,
you know,
like I almost knocked something off the counter or caught it real quick.
It's like everything's normal.
Like you body moves good,
but a,
you're like,
Ooh,
you feel weird.
You feel like,
Ooh,
you're under the physically,
mentally it's a very nice,
it's like,
yeah,
it gives you a body buzz,
but it's uh,
it's great at alleviating anxiety.
I'm going to,
it makes you really chill.
It's weird.
It's just like puts you in this nice headspace where you're just like,
ah,
like everything's calm.
And I think the idea is that it fills up these opium receptors.
And that's what,
uh,
what people that have had real problems with opiates,
that's why they like it.
Because even if you are fucked up on it,
you're not fucked up.
Like you're fucked up.
Like,
Woo,
I feel something.
So I'm crazy.
He's going on.
And I,
I was taking eight and uh,
my buddy Chris Bell,
he's the guy who directed that a bigger,
stronger,
faster documentary.
He had a real problem with opiates.
He got to a pretty serious,
a hip injury,
how to get hip replacement surgery and was in massive pain when he has a serious
arthritis like genetic arthritis.
And when he got his hip replaced and got on pain pills,
he got hooked bad in the middle of making a documentary about prescription
trucks,
which is crazy.
In the middle of it,
he got hooked himself,
just total random,
you know,
it was synchronicity and he takes 10,
he takes 10 of those.
So he takes two more than I took.
And I yesterday for like four hours,
I was walking around like this.
Ooh.
But there's no real like side effects in comparison to the other stuff.
No,
no real side effects.
After that last man standing tournament with Gloria had three fights in one
night.
My,
I had like super bad chest contusion on my chest is still there years later,
the swelling and swelling of my sternum and uh,
it would pinch off nerves running down my shoulder.
And then I think I actually pinched off the nerve root,
which is when I started doing the,
um,
the decompression with the chiropractor.
And so my left side started like getting,
like,
it was noticeably getting smaller,
like it was the muscle atrophies because we don't know is the WWE,
I didn't know you might know it Joe,
you know,
everything is that the nerve root actually feeds them the muscle and allows it
to grow without,
once that's fucked up,
then your muscle won't grow anymore.
It's when you atrophy and shit,
it's very difficult to get into the grow back to if you don't catch it quickly.
Right.
And uh,
did you have a problem getting into grow back or did you catch it quick?
Huh?
Well,
I think when we started doing the decompression and all that stuff,
it worked.
Um,
I mean it grew back I think.
but the,
the pain that I was feeling from all the shit I kept,
I kept getting Vicodin prescription for Vicodin or Norco and,
uh,
you're literally in pain.
So I would take them the medicine.
But,
um,
after like two months,
like I looked at my kitchen counter and there was just empty pill bottles,
like everywhere.
And I noticed that I was like really fucking aggressive and like short and like
I just stopped right away when I,
when I realized that,
but I could have told you,
you see how that would be,
that could become an addictive thing for sure.
That you really need it.
You know?
It wasn't like I was like trying to get fucked up.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm in pain and take a pill.
And then,
uh,
did you go to a doctor and get it looked at?
Yeah,
I went to,
what did they say about your sternum?
Uh,
they said that there was nothing wrong with it and went to the hospital twice.
I woke up,
uh,
America woke up,
like screaming and shaking from the pain and went to the doctor and the hospital
and they did an x ray and said,
there's nothing wrong with that.
And I'm like,
look,
the swelling,
it looks like a tennis ball.
And they said that it was in our cartilage or between the ribs are really had
gotten some sort of contusion.
No,
somebody gets a hit and elbow and their head swells up.
The mine was doing that under the rib or under the sternum plates or some shit.
So there's this constant pressure.
I just started taking Advil,
like it was going out of style and then that would make the swelling go down and
then I wasn't in pain anymore.
And the problem that I was having with the Vicodin was it's not an anti
inflammatory.
So it did nothing for the,
for the actual cause of the pain.
And I was just eating fucking Vikatin like crazy.
So,
um,
and then,
uh,
yeah,
but now I pretty much eat,
I take Advil every day regardless for my knees hurting or my toes are hurting
here.
Like,
just years of not supposed to fuck with that stuff.
It's not good.
Yeah.
You guys do the Onnit gut health,
right?
Well it's just,
that'll help.
I mean in a Kimchi helps to probiotics,
Kombucha,
right?
It just,
it ruins your gut health and it causes inflammation.
This is what my friend Cameron Hanes who runs ultra marathons,
he was taking 800 milligrams a day,
sometimes twice a day.
And uh,
cause he was in pain all the time cause he runs fucking dude runs a marathon
every day on Saturday night.
This Saturday coming up,
he's running for 24 hours and his goal is 120 miles in 24 hours.
I mean,
he's a fucking maniac.
So this dude's always in pain.
And uh,
I had doctor Rhonda Patrick on and she was explaining about how nonsteroidal
anti inflammatories like Ibuprofen actually cause inflammation because they fuck
up your gut bacteria and they fuck up your body's ability to process information
and it causes pain.
So he listened to,
there's,
there's connections to stroke and all sorts of other problems.
So he gets off of it and all his pain went away.
His pain was caused in part by the fact that he was taking this stuff for his
pain,
which is a terrible,
ridiculous,
vicious cycle.
What's happened for how long straight was he taking?
He was taking it for years.
For years.
Yeah,
he will,
because he's been a runner forever.
He's been doing marathons and ultra ran 238 miles last year.
The,
you know the Moab to 30 which is just the same.
Yeah,
we'll have to 40 impossible.
It takes three days.
Three fucking days.
What's really crazy is this.
Sorry you,
after the first day he woke up the next day,
another 24 hours of running.
So there's a type of mindset that you have to have to be able to do something
like that.
That's just superhuman.
You,
you have to be able to just every step,
left foot,
right foot,
agony and pain.
All your toenails are falling off.
Everything's in there.
I've seen them post pictures of little toes and nasty fucking feel fucked up.
Yeah.
What's crazy is a woman beat everybody by more than 10 hours.
A woman who I had on her name is Courtney Doh Altar and she beat everybody by 22
miles.
She was 22 miles ahead of the second place.
Dude,
that's unbelievable.
She's a fucking animal.
She slept for one minute and three days.
One Minute for a minute.
Sorry,
I'm a strong
chick.
22 miles.
Come on.
I don't think steroids help in that world.
I think in that world those people are just,
it's just mental.
I really,
I really don't think it helps get it a little bit.
They get sponsors and shit.
Cam doesn't get paid.
Me has sponsors under Armour sponsors them and right now,
but not really.
It's just because they're animals.
I know every step by be like she can,
she can see it like thinking about what am I doing this for?
Well it's also you're used to psychotic interactions with other people
in short amount of time.
Like you used to like 20 minutes and clear description.
Chaos.
I mean,
dude,
I,
that last man standing,
it was one of my favorite events I've ever been to.
I fucking loved it.
I don't want you to ever do it again cause I love you.
I don't want to fight fucking four times in a night.
Oh Man.
I kind of want to do it again.
It's so crazy.
There's something about doing that.
Uh,
you know,
you're doing something like special and,
and uh,
you know,
epic like that was,
that was my main,
the last men standing the tournament.
That was like my main focus after the,
after I knocked outside with Marcus and then I guess after a beat,
after the first two fights going into the third one,
like I'm pretty sure I wasn't going to beat our two most to beat up.
But I was like,
just had this crazy buzz about knowing that it was doing something like special,
like this was really fucking cool,
which I like to,
I would love to do it again.
I think that's how those people feel when they're running those crazy ultra
marathons to do something insane.
They've been a regular fight is insane to regular fights in the night is insane.
Three regular fights in the night against worldclass kickboxers and then the
first fight you had to go four rounds because after three rounds it was a draw.
What in the fuck man,
that's good.
Notify it.
Had to do that shit right now if you
get excited here.
I liked her.
I've always loved tournaments.
I've always wanted to be in like a day tournament.
I said it'd be dope.
Now you're making your move back to MMA because kickboxing is just not what it
should be.
I think we both feel that.
Yeah.
Kickboxing is one of my favorite things to watch.
I'm a giant fan of it and for whatever reason it is just not caught on in
America the same way boxing has or the same way MMA hat.
It's map and I've spent my whole,
well I meant doing this since I was 15 I'm 34 so all of that type I've been
thinking about this same question and then I'm just,
you know,
um,
it is what it is.
Yeah.
It's like you can't hold onto it anymore.
At least not for me.
The sport is going to grow,
is going to keep,
keep doing good.
And I hope that that continues.
But for me,
I need to do a to keep,
keep progressing,
so to speak.
That is a
did.
Here's what it is.
I mean,
that's the best way to put it because there's no way we're gonna fix it,
but I don't understand,
you know?
I mean,
I really,
really don't understand.
I fucking love watching kickboxing and when people tell me about how they love
boxing,
I'm like,
that's great.
Boxing is great.
I love boxing to kickboxing is way better than boxing,
right?
That that extra level of,
you know,
throwing in kicks and knees and,
and especially if you go to [inaudible] elbows and clinch,
it's just,
it's a wilder,
crazier striking sport.
And I just don't understand it.
I mean,
when I watch you fight,
or Kevin fied
or you know,
Kevin Ross or Giorgio Petrosian,
John Wayne par,
like,
how the fuck would you not want to watch that?
It's so exciting.
And then continuously like that.
They just don't,
they just don't tune in.
This doesn't,
it's like,
fuck,
I don't know what it is.
I just don't understand this.
Does Beltour have real problems with their ratings when they air it?
Um,
I've,
I don't know exactly what the ratings are.
I know that they're,
uh,
they're average.
They're not super fantastic on any,
so it's below what the average is for the MMA fights.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Man.
It's a bummer.
It's a real fucking bummer because for you,
for anybody who is a fan,
anybody who likes watching it like shit.
Like that event in La,
that last man standing,
holy fuck.
Was that fun?
That was crazy.
Yeah,
that was,
that was probably one of the best kickboxing events was the buscot boxing event
I've ever been too.
Yeah,
me too.
The whole energy and the forum just in general,
the layout of that was bad ass that,
yeah,
the farm is perfect for that.
I mean it,
and everybody knew it was a special night.
Like it was that it was crazy.
You know that they were doing this,
you know,
what is it like knowing that like how much time do you have in between your
second and third fight and everything is fucked up and sore and you know,
you're about to go into another fight.
Uh,
I think it's probably like 30 minutes,
30,
40 minutes,
maybe one more.
One other fight between you.
So just enough time for everything to start hurting.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I guess I was just,
because of the money,
like I knew that like each time my father was going to get more money and that
was like my focus in the 30 minutes.
Like not wanting to go back out,
never crossed my mind,
you know?
Versus if I think if I wasn't getting paid for it,
I'd be like,
oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
that was fine.
You know what I mean?
So that's why I was asking him about those ultra marathons,
how they actually get paid for it or not.
Cause I don't think that would be my main focus.
You say that.
But I think that if you were there,
just your competitive spirit would kick in and you would go,
let me see what I could fucking do here.
Give me another minute hand and a cigarette.
Yeah.
Mile 79 and you're like,
shit I'll have to do is 21 more miles.
I could do that.
Do you think you'd like to fight in a tournament?
Like old school,
Ufc one style?
Oh,
just one to uh,
you know,
being part of build towards tournament.
It was dope being a part of like a,
you know,
monthly tournament.
We always wanted it to be like,
you know,
yeah.
It was good wood again,
you know,
finding some of the best fighters in the world three times a night.
Yeah.
That's really what it's going to touch you to me.
So yeah,
there's so many factors involved.
So many variables,
right?
Like your opponent could get up
quick first round knockout,
right.
And you could go a three round war,
you know,
and then you face each other in the next round.
It's just,
I get the not wanting to do it anymore.
I get it.
The only place that would let you do is probably like one of them,
native American casinos.
It's like,
come on and Bob will actually come on in the commission.
Is the commission a problem?
I think they would do it in California.
Do you think that they did with glory when I did it?
Yeah,
but that's kickboxing.
I don't know if they would do that with MMA kickboxing.
It's wildly,
uh,
widely criticized though.
A lot of people think that was a bad idea.
I think the way they can do it with kickboxing is because of boxing.
The boxing,
a rule set is like you have up to 12 rounds or whatever.
So for kickboxing,
that's three fights.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I don't know how that works with them in a manner that makes sense with
kickboxing.
That make sense?
Because I think they probably would have a hard time saying like of Daniel can
fight 10 rounds of MMA tonight.
That's probably what's the most rounds of kickbox and you've ever fought in the
night.
But other than that,
that tournament like one single fight,
oh five,
five rounds when I was fighting weight times always.
I'll always like that.
Right.
Why is that?
Um,
I think that the rule set in Thailand is a based,
primarily around gambling.
It's like human cock fighting is what,
when we tie ism in Thailand essentially it sounds negative but it's kind of that
way.
Everybody in the audience is,
is gambling and they're betting out yelling and uh,
motioning back and forth,
the treatment bedding.
So like in Thailand it's a three minute round,
but it's two minute rest,
which I think is awesome is awesome.
But yeah,
I fought for the WBC world title over there and wow.
What year was this?
I don't know Jamie.
They play the music.
Yeah,
for sure.
And I find it out.
Roger Dominant in stadium and Thailand,
which is like one of them.
Wow.
And a loop.
Vinny are the two big ones.
So I fought over there.
Um,
uh,
the two minute rest is cool except that you kind of run out of things to talk
about,
like my coach now.
So I'm like looking at ring girls and they go out and you find a tie guy?
Uh,
no,
I'm both times.
No first time I fought a guy from Argentina at Roger Under in stadium.
And the second time I fought a car,
a pet Carpathian from golden glory gym for the WBC world title.
Now when you,
um,
fight over there in Thailand,
did they still expect Westerners to take it easy on that first round?
Because the idea is during the first round most ties they go fairly light
because there were ready for the bedding to get established.
They don't want any one of them.
I think you don't want to come out too strong because then nobody will bet on
you are against the other person.
Hmm.
Um,
I don't think they expect that from the foreigners though.
I think just as a whole,
they think that the foreigner suck.
I'm like,
they think like foreign is won't block lake kicks.
A lot of times you'll see like the ties come out and just wreck the fucking
foreigner in the first round if again,
so yeah,
I don't think they,
they're expecting the forerunners to participate.
Yeah.
I would love to go back in time and watch Ramon decker right when he first got
there.
Right.
And that was like the golden era
when we tie in like the nineties,
when when they didn't have the,
uh,
you know,
like right now it's the first round.
They don't really fight the second and third round.
They fight in the fourth round that they may or may not fight depending on who
won,
who won the first two.
They take it off because Brown,
they do nothing really.
I mean,
not nothing,
but almost nothing.
They're not really trying to win because they know they're going to fight in a
week.
Right.
And then like in the golden era was like,
when like those guys would come out and just,
it was,
it's a prime time and everybody would fight every round.
And uh,
it was supposedly was better.
Does Ramon decker fights?
Anybody who doesn't know anything about Moyie Thai,
go on Youtube right now and watch Ramon Dekkers and watch chaos.
That dude,
he fought guys who was his size to that was the,
what was interesting about him is like he was a small guy.
It wasn't like a big guy who's about going over there to fight the ties.
He was their size.
Yeah.
And he felt like the top,
top,
top
guys and like the,
and like their prime,
which is pretty rare now you see like Sanchez,
super famous but like same chai isn't is,
is like the celebrity guy who's fighting like the older,
heavier ties like the,
the top ties right now in Thailand at like 120 pounds,
15 pounds and they're like 16 years old.
There's like the top guys,
right?
Then you build a name where you're big enough name that the foreigners know
about you and the rest of the world and market you.
And then you fight.
You know,
you go to America and you find it an American,
you'd go to wherever.
So you be like,
uh,
San Chai,
blue cow.
Those guys.
He's fighting constantly and he seems to be fighting on the road a lot.
I'll go to these weird places and fight some dude who looks like he's in real
trouble almost immediately.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
Well they're like,
oh,
we're going to bring San shy over for this fight.
And then they got,
we've got to fight somebody.
They had tired.
Uh,
and then a lot of times the ties don't fight each other.
Like it's very rare that you'll see outside of like a tie stadium.
Um,
you know,
you never,
you're hardly,
you're not going to see Yahtzee Cli fi blue cow or like a tie versus tie.
They rent the ties to kill the foreigners and then still be on the same team.
Sanchez got such an interesting style too because if you looked at him,
if you only saw like a silhouette and you saw him move around,
you'd go immediately.
Oh,
that Sanchez.
You could tell instantly.
Yeah.
This is a constantly moving,
shuffling his feet,
switching back and forth,
real light on his feet.
He just moves different than everybody else.
He does like the old web or on some wiper on was like the original martial art
of the,
turned it into [inaudible].
If you watch like the old Tony John like on bark or they are like whatever and
they run up on your leg and like dropping the ball on your head.
It's like the Weber on stuff.
And like a lot of the techniques that Sandra does,
like the cartwheel kick or like the games that he plays,
uh,
alert Silla is another one that's really similar to him from the wash.
You just,
when they've met
Laird,
Zillow fight in lion fight against a do with zero fights.
Yeah.
They let them fight with zero fights.
The dude had zero Muay Thai fights over 400.
He got up to the top and he had kicked this dude into another dimension.
But it was one of those things where you,
it was inevitable from the first minute of the first round.
You're like,
this guy was an MMA fighter,
not a bad fighter,
but just doesn't belong in there with Laird Zillow.
It was ridiculous.
Yeah.
And when would I put it online?
The,
please don't ever do that again with Conor Mcgregor's going to fight Floyd
Mayweather.
Yeah.
That's for $100 million,
bro.
Yeah.
Kind of different.
Pretty sure lying if I didn't pay that guy anywhere close to that team,
pretty sure like I got his head knocked off for 1000 bucks and it wasn't the
same.
That guy's not Conor McGregor either,
you know?
Right.
I mean,
if Conor Mcgregor fraud alert Zilla and MMA fight or more Thai fight,
I go,
okay,
let's see what happens.
You know?
I mean,
I don't think he's going to win,
but that,
that might be interesting.
But you know,
seeing those guys and the,
the,
the real high level guys and seeing like what they're able to do,
seeing them the way they move and it's like,
it's so important for,
especially for MMA guys that don't understand the levels of striking,
right.
There's,
when guys are just striking,
there are just,
there's some elite upon elite upon elite levels,
you know?
I mean,
it's,
um,
it's such a black belt versus a blue belt.
Yeah.
Be like a really bad ass blue belt.
And then he'd be like,
go to the black belt.
You're just completely lost.
Like it's not even close to just getting dominated.
Yeah,
you can just get shut down,
you know,
or like you're a good high school wrestler and he'd go against like,
you know world chair.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean one of the more unique things about combat sports is that there are these
deep,
deep levels and you don't,
you know,
sometimes you need to see like a guy like Khabib,
number of Madoff is a perfect example.
You got to see him fight against guys who you know are bad ass and see him smush
them.
Just the real difference.
Right?
Yeah.
They realize like where this guy's at,
cause he's not doing anything.
It's not like he's doing it jumped three 60 wheel kicks in there that nobody
else can do.
He's doing things that everybody else does.
He's just doing,
I'm at a level that no one else is doing it now.
It's crazy.
He's wrestling.
It's like 10 times the level of like a lot of Russell's off say it could be,
have you ever trained with them?
Never tried or have you just impressing me with like,
yeah,
watching them fight.
Who is the best wrestler?
A American talked to him when you were there,
what would you think?
Do you think?
So best restaurant?
Yeah.
You
train with it.
What did I mean?
Wasn't a fighter had to be Brownie?
I mean,
brownies a dog.
Just coach wise.
He was just,
what's his name?
Mike Browning.
Browning.
Mike Brown wouldn't,
where's he out of att?
No,
but where it was he dresser.
I'm saying Mike Brown,
again,
not a,
um,
a,
a fighter was a coach,
Mike Brown and was probably the best wrestler at,
Oh,
the coach was
interesting.
Mike Brown in which he has had his hands.
He was some movement and strength.
It's just a dog.
And he wasn't a fighter.
Not just coaching.
Wrestling.
Yeah.
But he,
he had a college career too though.
Yeah.
Why did it go?
I think he was in Boston maybe.
Or what was my Brownie from up north somewhere.
So he's never had any MMA fights?
No.
Brownie has.
Yeah.
How many of you fuck,
fuck,
fuck off.
Fought for the UFC.
Fought for fucking,
um,
what was that before UFC,
what were that younger,
um,
beat Uriah,
uh,
you know,
had a very easy WC.
I had a good career.
Oh,
Mike Brown,
your son.
You're seeing browning.
Oh,
his Mike Brown.
I was like,
who is this browning?
Yeah.
So I said,
I'm like,
what the fuck this is talking about it.
I still don't know the fuck he fought for the UFC.
I'm going through my Rolodex.
Browning.
Browning Browning.
Who's browning?
Fuck No.
Mike Brown's referenced.
No,
he's a,
he was a bad motherfucker in his day.
Cool.
Mother fucker too.
Very good dude.
When I was done at eight 30,
like he was boiling.
Favorite person I fuck with,
I don't think of,
well,
he's a great
coach now too.
He was in Colby Covington scoring or this weekend and I told me after the fight,
he's like,
dude,
this kid's cardio is insane.
He's like,
it's insane.
He goes,
I think it might be like a,
just a natural gift that he has.
I mean,
he trains really,
really hard,
but he said his cardio,
it was just off the charts.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It's funny how much attention he's like,
I don't know if he wasn't that good before,
but this is why he got a ton of fucking intention.
As soon he started talking shit.
Oh for sure.
And they just taught as the champ or in the room.
Yeah,
well the talking shit got him to the dance.
But beating Maya,
the way he beat Maya,
everybody had to open their eyes up and go,
Huh.
But a lot of people had doubts.
They were like,
dos Anjos is a fucking straight up assassin.
He's going in there again against,
they got fucked up.
Robbie Lawler,
Gow Merch,
Neil Magni like how's he going to beat this guy?
And he beat the shit out of him.
He literally beat him every round.
I was crazy like he watching,
I mean maybe you could give the first round of Dos Anjos and you know,
he was always a threat because he's still got power.
But Colby is just on and it was like Nick Diaz style,
just pop,
pop,
constantly.
Constant attack,
constant kicking them,
constant punching him.
I was very impressed
back and watch it and then see it.
So I can't really say anything.
Very impressive men that the most impressive thing was the pace he put on them.
Cause they'll,
Santos is known for his cardio and he had a real problem with that cardio when
he was at one 55 cause he had diminished his body so much and then he moves up
to one 70 and you're like,
well now he literally doubled his output.
If you look at the strikes per minute in the 155 pound division and then one 70
it was double at one 70 and still Colby melted them.
Just just stayed,
stayed on and kept that heat on.
It was crazy.
It's impressive.
Very impressive.
But now he's got tyrant so mad Tyron wants to fucking kill him.
That's a different person like Tyron has.
Cause he hates him.
It's all the shit talking Coby has been doing.
He did.
He did interviews with people.
We told them don't bring up Colbys name.
I don't want you to even bring up his name because he didn't want Colby getting
in any attention.
But now it's too late.
Now,
Daryl doesn't want anyone's name other than his brought up all the time on any
show ever.
Period.
Ever,
ever
fight now he should be happy.
That guy talks a lot of shit now cause that's what's gonna make them money.
You're right.
I mean good for both of them.
Fuck yeah,
go for it.
How do you feel about shit-talking?
Yeah,
I was never ashamed of talking but because I never want to be that guy.
That Shit Talk Shit.
Come back it up.
So I like when people talk shit cause I'm a beat your ass anyway.
But you know it works for some.
It doesn't.
Like I said,
for me it was,
I was never one of those guys.
But it has been one of those things that like you see every,
every couple of years,
it's those one guy that stands out from talking shit and it's like I had worked
for him.
They,
you start to see everybody tried to trickle it,
right.
Well I think Connor did that for a lot of people.
But Colby saying some hilarious shit.
I'm gonna take this belt,
bring it to Donald Trump.
Fucking,
it's fucking fun though,
man.
It's the same thing Sheldon.
It's obviously fun,
like just,
that's obviously bullshit,
but it's,
it fucking works.
Yeah,
exactly.
But Chels still the bus make me go watch him talk about anything.
I just fucking like really like what?
He's a smart dude.
It's really good little,
his uh,
Instagram videos that he does and it's called,
we were fucking great.
They're excellent.
Fucking great.
I would take a class from jail on how to like talk shit.
Do that shit.
I would totally do it.
Yeah,
man.
When he was fighting Anderson Silva,
those,
those were the glory days of Shit.
Talking in MMA,
he opened up the door for everybody,
how they feed and the Nogueira brothers a carrot.
That carrot a bus was a donkey.
I didn't know that they had the internet there.
I swear.
I didn't know.
I thought it was on a private forum.
The Internet guys
balls.
He went over and did the ultimate fighter in Brazil.
I mean,
went over it to Brazil,
stayed there for six weeks and did the ultimate fighter and coached alongside
Vandelay and Vandelay got jumped by a DDA.
Yeah.
And Vandelay got so goofy on the show that Vandelay loss Brazilian fans,
cause Vandelia was coming after him and Cheo was trying to be calm about it.
And jails like,
look,
you know,
like don't touch me,
don't come near me.
And you know,
randomly comes near him.
He grabs him,
takes him down.
He's like,
what?
It was so it was so interesting like watching him turn it all around and people
mad at Vandelay.
I mean the Brazilians are mad at February.
They'll like,
you're making us look bad.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Plays a perfect,
perfect.
Yeah.
I mean there's a,
there's a time and a place for shit talking and this is the time and this is the
place.
Yeah.
It just seems like to make money now,
it's,
it's such a wise move.
I mean,
it's sports entertainment at the end of the day,
regardless of what anybody wants to say or think about it.
And like I'd rather,
I mean I'd watch two guys that aren't that good if I,
you know,
like the tough man contest.
If it's marketed right,
like the bouncers and bartenders,
like whatever,
like if it's entertaining,
it's entertainment.
Some of the best fights have been against guys who aren't some of the best
fighters.
Butter bean.
I'd love that guy was the best fights ever.
Sure.
I want to start like this fucking tough man contest promotions.
Even good guys who aren't world champions.
Like when a Toro Gotti fought Micky ward,
we knew that they were both perfectly matched and they would just going to
collide in the middle of the ring and beat the fuck out of each other.
But there's just some of the classic boxing matches
for sure.
Didn't have to be for the heavyweight championship.
No,
no,
no.
I mean there's some been some amazing fights in the UFC.
There's similar to that,
like Gilbert Melendez versus Diego Sanchez.
Right.
That wasn't for a title.
I was one of the greatest fights of RC.
That shit was crazy.
The whole classic style makes bikes.
I mean,
I've always liked the shifts.
Two fighters that don't really have too much online and talking shit about a
fight hype.
The hype behind the fight is what makes,
you know.
Yeah.
As long as you can actually still fight.
And that's what makes it interesting with the guy like Conor or a guy like Colby
day can fucking fight.
They're talking a lot of shit.
But when and when?
The,
when the bell rings,
they're backing it up.
I mean,
we were talking about this earlier,
but that's what bugs me the most about cm punk was the,
he has the,
the,
uh,
WWE back on,
you would think you'd be least be like great on the mic.
You know what I mean?
And they're like,
maybe we can't back it up or fight or whatever.
But like,
he goes from like cocky and confident,
I'm the fuck a jab or whatever that we're going to be easy to like,
ah,
you know,
I just believe in yourself.
Kids.
Like,
it's like really hard to,
I don't believe anything has no physical,
like no physique.
He doesn't at least not like it's a,
it's Kinda sad.
[inaudible] I just shit on cm punk.
No,
listen,
you didn't shit on them.
You were honest about them.
You were honest about what you saw.
I don't think that shitting on him.
Right.
He's a very nice guy.
He's a very nice guy and he's a hard worker,
but he does not have athletic talent.
He's missing a lot.
And he's a showman.
And when he was in the WWE,
he was allowed to say hi,
I'm the fucking man.
Marriner throw his arms up there.
And they had it scripted so that he was the man.
But you know when you're in there with a guy like Mike Jackson who had zero fear
of him and just was so casual and just popping them in the face anytime you
wanted to and literally can stop them anytime.
If he just got angry and want to stop him,
he could have stopped him at any point in the fight.
And even though he beat him decisively,
the performance was Ipis Dana white off so bad
the way he was fighting that he called him a fucking idiot.
And he said,
I'll never fight in the UFC again.
And he won.
So like if Mike Jackson went out there and just start cm punk with a right hand
left hook combination,
and that was the end of it,
they would say,
well cm punk,
you gave it a shot.
That's it.
It's over.
Mike,
who would you like to fight next?
And now it's like,
you know,
you're not even fighting in the UFC anymore because you should've,
you should've stopped him like what you were doing.
He tickled them.
You fucking tickled to them.
I'll make a joke of the sport like it's already like a joke.
If this guy,
you know,
everyone thinks cm funks like fucking joke.
I guess he is.
If that's the way they look,
but like don't make a joke of the sport and like not know.
They kind of just like poke in front of the fence.
I get worthiness coming from,
I get,
we're doing this.
Come on.
It's too,
I'd a starched him.
Yeah,
it's the whole thing was,
it was very weird.
The whole thing was very weird.
It was like right away when you see cm punk holding,
holding his hands up and moving stiff and throwing kicks like,
oh Jesus.
Like I don't like that being on paper view.
I understand that they,
they're selling paper view cards,
but paper view in the UFC should be the elite fighters.
Curtis blades versus Alistair Overeem should have been on that paper view card.
That's what should have been there.
Not,
not what we got to see.
You know what we got to see was just,
yeah,
I like when it's like,
like you're playing a trick on the fence,
you know what I mean?
He promoting this guy if you something and then it's like sparring videos come
out and it's like,
what the fuck is this?
Sparring videos are crazy.
Awful.
It was like a guy who just showed how to spar.
It's like you took a dude who's no wrestling background,
no nothing.
Or this one I want you to do,
this is a jab.
This is the right hand and this is when you throw a kick.
I want you to pivot your hips.
Go ahead in there as spar.
I mean he just,
he doesn't have the ability to move his body.
Right.
There's a lot of guys you could take out there that are,
um,
track and field guys or football players and you could get them to fight better
than him and a couple of weeks right.
Easily because they're athletes,
they're athletes.
They would understand how to shift their weight,
throw a punch,
and yeah,
the,
the sparring videos that I saw was,
I think it was from his first fight,
but even then,
like he wasn't,
he signed for like two years before he had his first fight or something like
that.
There's no way that you're six years deep in the game and yet he's still at that
bad.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't have any talent.
That's all it is.
It just doesn't have physical talent or whatever for whatever reason,
whether it's a,
he,
his approach,
his intensity,
whether it's,
it's not as coaching.
He said Duke fucking Rufus,
you know,
I mean,
I have a house with Cushman that he talks about two groups and one of the put
pre fights.
He said,
uh,
how do you see this fight?
He's like,
oh,
I really like a head kick to,
I'd love to see a head kick.
And like,
I don't think that's going to happen.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
That,
so that's such a crazy thing to say.
Um,
you know,
Duke's a beautiful person.
He's a,
he's a great guy in every,
every sense of the word.
He just is,
he's a great guy.
He did his best.
You know,
there's only so much you could do,
you know,
I mean,
I'm sure
you would love working with Duke.
I'm sure he would love working with you if you and Duke work together.
I'm sure you guys would have a great old time because you're Joe fucking
shillings,
right?
And he's Duke fucking relevance,
you know,
let them know.
But you know what I mean?
I mean,
you have to have something to work with,
you know,
I mean,
if Duke just grabbed some dude from a gas station that has been,
uh,
drinking beer and smoking cigarettes his whole life and had him in a fight in
six months,
how much can you pause?
But I would rather see that fight against these other ones.
Let's find out how that one would go.
Well,
a guy,
you can find it a gas station Berens there.
What's interesting is they both,
both guys fought Mickey Golf first.
Just weird.
Did you see his Instagram?
Mickey's,
yeah,
he did like his own pre fight.
Uh,
what do you analysis of how it was going to go?
It was really good.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
that was a disaster when I saw Mickey fight and then I saw that it was going to
fight cm punk.
I was like,
who said Yes to this?
Why the fuck would you say yes to this?
This is 100% guaranteed brain damage.
There's no way you're going to beat him.
There's not,
you don't have a goddamn chance in hell.
You have no chance.
And I was saying that people get mad at me.
The CM punk fans get mad at me.
I'm like,
look,
this is what I do.
My job is to analyze shit.
I look,
I look at fighters,
I look at me,
I understand what I'm talking about,
man.
This is like,
I'm good.
I got a pit bull and I'm going to put them in a cage with a puppy.
What do you think's going to happen?
The pit bull is going to kill the puppy.
This is what,
this is how it works.
This isn't like,
this isn't like maybe that puppy going to grab him by the face.
No,
no,
no.
Listen to me.
I'm telling you,
this is how bad this matchup is.
This is uh,
this is a Brazilian jujitsu brown belt with a nasty back game.
It was strong and fast.
You look at,
uh,
the matchup with a cm punk.
Just had Mike Jackson Mickey and beat my checks in and I'm like under a minute
and smashed him.
Took his back,
strangle him.
He said he's a bit,
I hear training with me for like the three months now and the kids getting
really good.
His striking is getting really,
He's fucking talented.
Matt.
Really good.
And he talks a lot of shit too.
Yeah,
he's good.
Plus has got hilarious walk out music when it comes out that,
oh,
Mickey yesterday tried to convince him ever since he got here,
I called his phone and it's like,
you know those people that have this ring back songs and they're like fucking
horrible.
Yeah.
Elevator music.
And he answers and I'm like,
dude,
turn that fucking shit off.
He'd change it or at least have it be.
Hey Mickey,
you're so fine.
Yeah.
What is his music that he had them on some trash.
It's an
elevator.
Like something off.
Fucking change it.
Mickey,
Change Your Buddy.
When is he fighting again?
Uh,
I don't think it has anything booked yet.
We're a,
I think he's,
he's calling Sean.
Sean Shelby.
So he's working with you with this tracking?
Yup.
Nine.
No,
he's helped me with my ground game.
And who is he working with?
His ground game out here?
Uh,
uh,
Jason Manly and uh,
Bomba fast come solace.
Where's that?
Out of a Bama
trades of me and Jason Manly is a,
the training that muscle farm.
That's cool.
So where is he a,
is he staying at Burbank out there?
Is He staying there?
You,
he's a stay in there.
Me and um,
uh,
Eagle Rock.
Nice.
She's actually roommates with Eve Edwards.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right here.
We got me to live for getting this little little love eve getting this dude.
They didn't go on.
Yeah,
man.
He's great isn't he?
He's a great dude.
He's a very good on the desk too.
It's interesting to see like a former fighters on the desk.
Like some dudes are loss and some dudes are smooth.
You know,
some things are very good at it.
He's,
I think he's as great.
Right?
It's very good.
I think he's one of my favorite ones to watch.
Yeah.
I tweeted about it up like years ago when he first started doing it.
I'm like die.
I really appreciate him doing that.
You know?
Um,
Michael Bisping is very good at it too.
Although his Colby got out,
it was a little awkward.
They went after it after the,
uh,
after the fight.
Like Bisbing can't not talk shit.
Right.
He can't help himself,
which I kinda,
I kinda,
I really appreciate that about and actually,
well he's,
he's a dog man.
His,
his competitive drive is pretty intense.
You know,
Bisping is in my opinion like one of the best,
but he's like one of the best poster boys for just hard work,
mental toughness and determination and also being that like British dude at the
bar that are like have a beer and tell you to go fuck herself and piss off
mother.
Yeah.
That's good.
He's got problems with his other eye now too.
It does.
He,
yeah.
You got some sort of a detachment and his other eye is good.
I thought they were going to fix fixed one.
I thought it was like going to get better or something.
Well they would get it done.
He's got some sort of oil in it that protects it before he retires and then when
he retires he's going to get it operated on to fix it.
But now he has a new problem with his right eye.
He was seeing some flash or something like that and his right eye and he went to
the doctor and found out it's got of detachment there and he's like,
all right,
fuck this.
I'm done.
Cause he was going to have one more fight.
Yeah.
And now he's like,
I'm done.
He did it all man.
Yeah.
He won the ultimate fighter.
He won the title,
you know,
in Haiti and,
and now he's,
he's a good analyst to go to the desk cause she think go on his podcasts.
I think you're great too.
He's doing good.
That is a nice thing to yep.
Get some movies.
Yeah.
He's always got something going on.
Um,
it's nice that guys do have those other options too,
like podcasts and different things.
Now there's,
there's ways out,
you know,
especially you look at like what's Shobbs done.
Shop has taken it to a whole nother level as far as guys being able to get out
of the,
out of the fight game and then make a living as a podcast.
And he's fucking doing stand up now and headlining clubs and shit and traveling
all over the country.
And He's good man.
He's fucking funny.
He's a funny dude.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
You know,
it's just nice that fighters have options because you know,
seeing the guy stick around when he shouldn't be doing it anymore.
It's one of the hardest things for sure.
And then he looked like all the NFL guys or any pro sport of these guys are
broke by the end up with him like four years of when they finish.
And uh,
yeah,
there's not a whole lot of other options for a lot of the guys.
So I think it's good.
It's nice that we have other options for sure.
So would you sign it?
You showed everybody the way your job,
there's a way,
you know,
there's ways now,
especially with the Internet man,
there's just crazy ways.
I mean,
how much money think mighty mouse makes on his twitch stream would say a decent
amount.
I don't know how much this is like the video game dudes twitch stream and they
not even like the best gamers in the world and they make thousands and thousands
of dollars and would write pages on there all the time.
Would you say something right now?
Sugar.
Sean's in it too.
Not that I'm going to watch it,
but yeah,
it's on rampage does that too?
I think so.
Yeah.
He's like a big camera.
He's always talking about is he still active?
Is he still gonna fight again?
Yeah.
I was trying to get a fight with him not too long ago and uh,
I'm not sure what,
he's like 290 pounds right now.
I feel like I still like figuring it that for that size.
I could do that.
I'd be like,
you could do that.
That could be and pitch.
I don't know if I'd go for like Brock Lesnar.
Okay,
well the rental,
we'll cut it anyway.
We're talking about fee because he doesn't,
he doesn't try to take you down.
Right.
Most likely he's going to try to stand with you,
right?
Yeah.
Do you have a set schedule for when you returned to MMA?
Uh,
I'm hopefully getting,
get something around September,
August,
late August,
early September,
I think.
And you just decided that we're kickboxing is right now,
just doesn't have enough juice.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
uh,
you know,
I want to keep us progressing financially and uh,
uh,
like I said,
money motivates me a lot and uh,
if I've reached the ceiling of the sport so to speak,
and there's,
Oh,
I'm amazed right here,
right next door and uh,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
No,
it does.
Yeah.
I mean,
how many more years you think you've got to do it?
Uh,
four,
five,
five.
Yeah.
I want to make big fights as much money as I can.
Um,
and set up for,
you know,
life after fighting.
I think,
you know,
you can't just quit.
Right.
You got to find ways to market yourself to the highest level,
to give as much attention as possible.
So the irrelevant in the space that you pass.
And I just don't think that kickboxing is going to get me there,
you know?
Yeah.
Man,
it's a bummer.
But I think you're right.
I think it's a smart,
if you're just dealing with strictly financially,
I think it's a very smart move.
It's very unfortunate.
I really wished there was a solution.
I do not know what it would be though.
I mean,
everybody's tried.
Spike TV tried.
They tried with the paramount network.
A,
they tried with glory,
you know.
Well I think it also with pellets tore it.
You know,
maybe I'll come back new.
There's a big fight,
you know,
maybe Musashi's like,
you know what I think I want the bells were kickboxing entitled to be
right.
Yeah,
let's do it.
So,
yeah.
Um,
but I would fight if they let me,
I would fight fucking kickboxing first,
win
that fight and then come back out the same night and fight him a man.
Really?
Hell yeah.
I brought it up.
I brought it up to coker at a a meeting not too long ago where they say,
they just kind of looked at me like,
ah,
the same way they looked at me when I said I would have to fight rampage of
Vandelay.
Ah,
yeah.
Well his deal is he back like what's going on with Vandelay?
I don't know.
I just saw it as a an opportunity when shale beat him,
you know his complaint was it,
you know,
he just took a bath and laid on top of them.
It's just been kind of my complaint for a while so I figured,
but they don't want that fine.
Yup.
Why don't they want that?
But well I think Vandelay already had his face surgery doesn't want suddenly go
on set with them twice
a rampage is my buddy,
but he just,
he just doesn't want that way.
He said he wants an easy fight like vividly so.
Well there's a lot of history between those two guys too.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
She would want to fight for him.
Yeah,
he was a vantage.
It was an interesting story to write when he was fighting over in pride and then
he came over to the UFC.
It just completely different human being,
you know,
just in the rampage fights when rampage fought him over in prod and it also a
lot of miles on them too.
Right.
You got to think of both things,
you know.
Yeah,
she's got me thinking about felony,
talking about,
uh,
you know,
fighting him
over the felony,
the fight or flight crazy horse.
Crazy horse has now changed his name to felony ladies.
Gentlemen no longer refer to him as crazy yours.
You ever see that fight backstage
is nothing they swear swears up and down.
Yeah,
I beat him up.
Uh,
like,
all right,
so the sleep that he definitely would chose to somebody else.
Right.
Was somebody else?
Uh,
but didn't he k he says he CalEd Vandelay said he sucker punched him after he
got choked out on the video that you see,
he fought later on that night and won by knockout,
I think after being choked unconscious in the back.
He said he knocked out Vandelay Oh yes.
And Zander.
No,
no,
no.
It happened before.
He fought in the locker room and he went out and won.
And then he,
he says he knocked out Vandelay punched him and knocked him out.
Vandelay went out and won a decision.
So Vandelay right.
If he's telling the truth,
he k Vandelay earlier that night.
Yeah.
This is it.
Here's the fight.
This is Vandelay when you know that doesn't even look like the same person.
I know his nose was smashed in.
Same Person.
Yeah.
That one's got like the Mario Brothers must,
he tacked this dude and he got caught in a triangle.
Very danger.
Danger.
That's it.
I forget who it was that did this to him,
but it was a one across in Greece.
He's black belts.
How big is,
how big is a felon,
Gary?
Now you got it all here it is 150.
Five pounds maybe.
Probably.
Yeah,
he's out cold here.
All
right.
Yeah.
Out Cold.
Well,
they're very nice to him.
Where like they slammed,
I believe his eyes opened up.
What I think like,
uh,
you did a,
I saw a clip the other day,
the guys who asked you,
uh,
what's the practical use of Jujitsu and you're like,
well,
the street,
if we got in a fight,
I would kill you.
That's like,
I think people don't realize that like without the ref to like stop the fight or
like though even those guys,
like they stopped him.
Like,
okay,
yeah,
I'll let him go.
He's already unconscious like that would kill you if you would be dead.
You would be dead if that guy doesn't want to let go of you like you does.
Hold on till your brain doesn't work anymore.
And that's a wrap and that's that.
That's real shit.
That's my friend Eric trying to come up with some excuse to not work out.
That's why I said what's the practical?
She's Jujitsu.
We had a fight I would kill.
You know the crazy horse fight is two guys in the basketball court.
I got to a big fight and then he takes it down and really,
really quick.
He tacked the guy.
Oh yeah,
he fucked up.
So on.
Oh yeah.
Oh He's,
he thinks he's a bad ass and he doesn't add a fight.
Oh look at this.
Oh,
oh.
Punching the back of the head.
Oh Shit.
Ooh,
look at this
again.
Are you still trying to punch him?
Hilarious.
It's taking that leg apart though.
Right here.
He's got them in the heel hook right here.
Cause I play basketball again by the fun that's in that position.
He's telling the truth.
Yeah.
Right.
All he has to do is
that fucking thing up clockwise and that's a rap pop,
pop,
that horrible pain of getting,
he'll hooked and not Tappan.
Yeah.
Not The business.
Especially that inside.
He'll hook that is so nasty when it goes across the body that the amount of
torque on your knee,
this is like no way unique and hang in there.
It just rips apart.
I'm good on knee surgeries.
Is that that polarez
well he do.
He does outside in inside,
but the inside one is just the outside one.
You got a little bit more,
there's a little more movement like this.
I mean you've got to tap,
but the problem is when someone's got you in this way across the body and then
they go like that man,
you got about an inch or two above it and
just,
it's horrible too.
It sounds terrible.
You can hear a duck.
Everything pulling apart and snapping off the bone and people screaming.
Paul Harris would not let go either.
That was his thing.
He would just hang on to heal hooks.
It sounds so bad.
I got a guy with a fucking Komora there was America and uh,
not sure what the differences,
but uh,
it sounds like at this is an Americana.
This is the Camorra
I think it was this way and uh,
it sounded like ripping a towel,
a Terry cloth towel.
If you pull it all apart and the fibers start popping,
that's what it sounded like.
It's still hear it in my head.
Oh,
three tap.
I mean after,
and then he's like,
oh,
it's,
it's cool,
it's cool.
And I'm like,
that's fucking cool.
I didn't mean to break your fucking arm.
He could have just tapped dickhead.
Yeah,
I saw,
I got to hear this shit in my head all night.
I saw a video of a street fight.
There's another video where the dude gets a guy in an Alma Plata and he's,
he's,
he's pushes arm up.
You see the guys arm just give out.
Oh,
the street fight.
I saw like Mexico or Brazil or something.
Yeah.
Good groundwork though.
He's nice.
I Alma Plata in a street fight.
It's always a plus.
I mean that's the street fight game is changing drastically,
dude.
We're dangerous.
Dangerous kid who was like on the playground.
It was like flying like karate kid shit.
Now they're going to be like rear naked choke and each other,
a little kids,
little kids grow up watching Bela torn the SC and kickboxing.
They know what a leg kick is.
Now they know all that shit.
They know how to grab the back of the head.
Other kids would yell,
Ni,
they know what to do now.
I was this it.
Yeah,
this is it.
this is awful.
The dude gets,
he brings out Lego.
That guy,
the guy on the top has no understanding of what to do with is over here it is.
Oh Sir.
I'm just going to,
here comes here,
comes here,
comes,
watch this,
get ready and here comes to noise.
Awful man.
The sound.
Oh,
there it is.
Oh
look at it.
Just laying fucked up backwards on his arm.
Oh,
don't move it.
Jesus Christ.
He's just laying there like
he must've been drunk too.
Cause he's like,
he didn't even pull his arm out.
He had no idea what he was doing.
Listen.
Yeah,
you guys see though,
you don't know you're in trouble.
Smoke Daniel.
Is that what that is?
Cigarettes there.
These are empty.
It was something else in here.
Come on man.
Something else.
Do you smoke cigarettes?
Yes.
Yes I do.
How often you smoke?
Soon as I get out of here.
As soon as you get out of here.
How many,
how many a day?
I tried to go,
uh,
I don't know.
Probably about half a back.
Jesus hanging out with this motherfucker.
Tell.
Okay.
This is part of it.
You just got to get it in.
He's can take it.
Just go ahead.
Get Him.
Joe,
why?
Just looking out for your best interests.
You ever tried to switch to vape or anything like that?
Uh,
I've done man.
Listen,
I've done it all vape.
I've chewed,
uh,
tried to stop gum.
Everything.
I just,
I'm a individual.
you an individual.
One of those weird guys.
Were you smoking when you were,
when you were the current w uh,
bellatore champ holds.
I was,
damn,
that's so crazy.
I miss walking since I was like chewing in smoking since I was 1213
there's a lot of Thai fighters or smoke,
right?
Scar Bosky doesn't need,
doesn't he always smoke?
Yeah.
Does that makes that a lot of five male,
a lot of fires.
I want to like put it out there like book Billy Bob last but a lot of fighters
that you know at high level in the UFC you smoke cigarettes.
I know I used to try to hide it like they used to be one thing,
you know and trying to hide it.
Oh and then you always say,
oh I can't believe your athlete and you're smoking until like leave me the fuck
alone.
They will hear you talk and they go man,
well you an 80 year old blues singer Fuck's going on with your voice man.
Just cigarettes.
They give you that hard living voice.
There is definitely a benefit and a level to like not hiding who you are.
I was just talking to somebody about that today.
Like it is nice.
I could say I smoke weed and feed myself and you know,
whatever
shit,
especially weed,
you know,
I mean there's a lot of people that have some dumb ideas about what weed does to
you,
you know?
And it's nice that guys like you are out about it so he could realize like no
real nice you guys like you are out there to pro athletes.
I be like,
I'm a stoner,
I'm a comedian.
It's like it makes sense.
But pro athletes like seeing like that a guy like who takes care of his body,
smokes weed.
It's not,
it's not ruined in his car.
The other thing is that the people want to think that it's lazy.
Yeah.
That's what bothers me most about the [inaudible].
Like the misconception of it is like that you're not a productive person that
you just sit around in the house in Ohio.
But someday,
like on Sunday I sit around the house high as a motherfucker,
that shit.
But every other day I'm working my ass off constantly.
In those days off though,
for sure,
for sure.
There's a photo in the green room from a Ryan Loco.
Shout out to she had,
that's why you a smoking cigarettes?
Is that from last man standing?
Okay.
It's in between fights.
Uh,
yeah.
I think it will.
Um,
I dunno if it was the last man standing or if it was,
it was a locker room.
One of the glory fights.
I don't know if it was between flights or not.
Yeah,
there it is.
That's up in the green room right now.
Eddie,
you're their officers.
It was like a Jimmy Hendrickson and Elvis.
Right at the same,
the 40.
Yeah.
I got a gang of new ones coming now.
I got um,
Steven Tyler when he was a teenager,
got arrested for weed.
I got him,
I got Conor Mcgregor,
Conor Mcgregor mugshot.
I got the real Jimi Hendrix mugshot.
Not the,
not the photo that we had on before,
which was like his real mugshot label.
But the photo was like from one of them,
Jimmy Hendrix experience photos.
We've got the real mugshot photo now.
Jimmy Hendrix had up heroin and I'm trying to go to Toronto with that heroin.
Here it is right there.
Yeah.
When someone's tried to tell me Jimi Hendrix didn't do heroin.
Well tell that to the Toronto Police Department when they fuck it.
Arrested him for it.
There's a picture of me on Instagram I saw the other day that was a Bruno Mars
fucking Justin beaver.
I like to other Brits celebrities,
wherever they were all smiling in their mugshot and it was like,
wouldn't you know you have bail money?
Yeah,
they just got Vince Vaughn.
Yeah.
They just busted him.
Dui.
Ah Sucks.
Good chicken and drivers look good.
I got both.
I got a Dui when I was 2022 on shrooms,
shrooms and
patent.
They didn't give me for this room.
It's Bro,
they fucking out me for the deal.
I would think that maybe the shrooms would help balance out the booze.
The real problem was I kept arguing with the guy and he was like trying to get
me to blow on the street.
And I'm like,
oh yeah,
nothing happening like pretending to blow.
And then they take me downtown and I was like in and out of like falling asleep
and they kept like waking up and they had like the Dui,
uh,
the breathalyzer machine looks like Kinda like this or whatever,
the actual big machine.
And I remember it like argument.
I'm like,
what if was,
if I don't blow?
And he's like,
the near you get suspended for six months.
And I'm like,
and what if I blow and it's a d and I,
and it's bad as a unit.
It was suspended for a year.
And I'm like,
and then I asked him that back and forth like 20 times I kept falling asleep.
I ended up not blowing,
but uh,
that would make you want to not blow like,
yeah,
fucking stupid.
So by the time he'd go to jail or you go to court anyway,
your suspension is almost up.
So I ended up,
I ended up getting off on that because it was,
uh,
they pulled me over for turning the wrong way on a one way street,
but I just showed that I wasn't,
I didn't do any field sobriety tests.
I'm not,
you shouldn't drink and drive.
I'm trying to back that.
But if you do drink,
I uh,
I didn't do the field sobriety tests so they didn't have any probable cause that
it was actually drunk.
And then when he didn't blow and uh,
they said,
well,
he was driving the wrong way to one way street.
And I was like,
I've never been to that area before.
So side note technique,
help blow it.
Don't blow.
Yeah,
never had a Dui.
Good for you.
Good at driving a fucking motorcycle,
man.
You better be silver
plus you're smoking cigarettes,
not paying attention what you're doing.
I mean,
with Uber and Lyft and all this shit now it's Kinda,
it's a pretty irresponsible to get a fucking Dui.
I bet it's dropped down significantly because of Uber and Lyft.
I really bet it has for sure.
I think so.
Listen Boys,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Thanks for bringing me all this stuff,
Daniel.
Much love and appreciate you and me,
man.
Hey,
my pleasure,
dude.
And Best of luck in your recovery.
It's a great story.
I love hearing it and I just,
all the best,
Matt Joe Schilling,
you know,
he my man and,
uh,
Daniel Straus on Twitter and on Instagram.
Joseph Schillinger scores chilling.
You know what?
I had this fucking plan.
I was just going to keep saying my,
uh,
my Instagram password throughout the whole show and I fucking forgot to Joe on
his course chilling on Instagram.
They go,
Holler at your boy how aleks score.